bonjour à tous soit nous sommes réunis
ici pour la nuit des cathédrales 2021 la
collégiale notre-dame de mantes-la-jolie
va se refaire une jeunesse le temps d'un
soir une visite guidée théâtralisée qui
débutera en 1840 avec alphonse durant
restaurateurs de la collégiale
collégiale c'est un spectacle itinérant
nom qui commence devant le parvis de la
collégiale et ensuite ça le il ya le
tour de la collégiale avec des arrêts
sur différents lieux sur les chats la
chapelle les gens vont avoir vraiment
une visite et vont redécouvrir les lieux
dans
comme ils ont jamais sûrement vu pour la
deuxième fois après l'édition 2019 la
mairie de mantes la jolie a fait appel à
la compagnie des trois couleuvre est une
compagnie de territoire qui oeuvrent sur
les territoires pour aller en lien avec
les habitants avec avec les espaces on
s'adapte aux différents endroits comme
là où on joue dans une collégiale les
comédiens vont faire vivre leurs
personnages tout en parlant également de
ces points historiques
l'idée c'est de passer un moment voilà
deux agréables de spectacle tout en
apprenant aussi des chaussures la
collégiale une déambulation dans
l'édifice entre théâtre interaction avec
le public
deschamps
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
un spectacle qui se veut chaleureux et
convivial dans un endroit déjà bien
connus démente et c'est aussi l'un des
buts j'ai la sensation de la compagnie
c'est à chaque fois d'investir des lieux
dans des endroits que les gens ont
l'habitude de devoir de connaître de
traverser et 2
venir peut-être apporter un nouvel
éclairage un nouvel angle avec des
personnes qui ont habité là il ya
longtemps ou alors des personnages de
contes mais du coup essayer de faire re
découvrir les endroits de façon un peu
différente
le tout avec une petite surprise à la
clé disons qu'il ya un personnage qui
milieux à peu près de spectacles qui
peut être surprenant qui
voilà qu'on va laisser aux gens le
plaisir de découvrir un personnage qui
revient du fonds de temps immémoriaux
fin du suspense et début de la
représentation ce samedi 24 juillet à 19
heures